نعم لكن دعني اوضح بعض التفاصيل بخصوص
اعداد الشهداء هذه الاعداد لم تندرج
اسفلها او لم يحصر داخل هذه الاعداد
الشهداء الذين يتم دفنهم على الطرقات او
في الممرات او في حتى مراكز الاواء التي
يتم قصفها في مختلف الاماكن فهذه الحصيله
هي تقديريه بالاضافه الى بالاضافه الى
المفقودين عشرات المفقودين اسفل الانقاظ
فبالاسحار منزلا قرب جامعه الازهر وهذا
المنزل يحتوي على ماء يقارب 60 مفقودا حتى
هذه اللحظه حاوره الاهالي انتشال الكثير
من الشهداء لكن يبدو ان المنزل هو مكون من
ثلاث طوابق ولا تستطيع العائلات انتشال
الجثامين من اسفل هذه الانقاض بسبب عدم
توفر اي من المعدات الثقيله وهذا امر صعب
جدا صراحه ان الكثير من الشهداء ما زالوا
اسفل الانقاظ ولا تستطيع طواقم الدفاع
المدني ولا حتى الاهالي ولا حتى الجيران
سوى الانتشال ببعض المعدات البسيطه التي
يعني تكون فقط الشهداء المتناثرين الملون
خارج هذا المنزل بفعل القصف العنيس العنيف
تطايرت اجزاء اجسادهم خارج هذا المنزل
فيبقى المفقودين عددهم كبير جدا ورجحت
بعض المنظومات الصحيه او عفوا المصادر
الطبيه ان الاعداد كبيره جدا لكن في
الترجيحات انها تزيد عن 11 ال مفقود في
مدينه غزه مدينه زه ايضا هناك الكثير من
الشهداء الان في منطقه
ال صحيح في شوارع مدينه غزه والان
بالتحديد في منطقه المشاهره ومنطقه حي
التفاح والدرج هذه المنطقه التي تحولت الى
مصرح عمليات صباح اليوم توجهنا انه هناك و
هناك الكثير من الشهداء على الطرقات وفي
الممرات هذه المنطقه التي دخلت قوات
الاحتلال اليها صباح اليوم وتقربت في
مختلف المناطق الكثير من الشهداء في هذه
المنطقه ولا نستطيع انتشالهم هذه المنطقه
مثلها مثل الكثير من المناطق من قبل ففي
منطقه الساحه حينما انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
ومنطقه الشجاعيه ومنطقه حي الشيخ رضوان
وبالاضافه الى منطقه تل الهواء ومخيم
الشاطئ هذه المناطق كانت مليئه بالشهداء
الملق على الارض بفعل قتل قوات الاحتلال
او القصف او القنص ولم يستطيع احد
انتشالهم فالكثير من الشهداء الان
يتواجدون في منطقه التفاح والدراج ملقون
على الارض ولا يستطيع احد انتشالهم او
التقرب الى اماكن تواجدهم طيب اسماعيل
يعني يفترض ان هنالك قرارا صدر من مجلس
الامن رغم كل التحفظات عليه من قبل كثيرين
لكنه يسمح بوصول المساعده
بدون عوائق الى قطاع غزه والى كل مناطق
قطاع غزه انتم في الشمال كنتم تعانون قبل
الهدنه المشهوره اياها هل هل وصل اي شيء
يصل اي شيء الى شمال قطاع غزه الى غزه
ومناطق
الشمال نعم هذه النقطه تحتوي على الكثير
من التفاصيل في ظل الواقع الصعب الذي
نعيشه لكن المساعدات وصلت الى منطقه مدينه
غزه وهي مساعدات بسيطه ففي الايام الاخيره
لاحظنا تحرك جيد او حركه ملحوظه من وحدات
اليو ان والامم من وحدات الامم المتحده
واليونيسيف وصلت الى هذا المكان مرارا
ويزيد عن ثلاث مرات اوصلت المساعدات
الطبيه وا وا اخبرتنا المصادر الطبيه ان
هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات بسيطه ولا تحتمل
ولا تقدر الطواقم الطبيه تشغيل غرف
العمليات لعده امور اولى هذه الامور عدم
توفر الطاقم الطبي ايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك
هناك مصادر تحدثت عن وفو طبيه خلال هذه
الايام سل معك اسماعيل لكن د نو فقط الى
هذا الخبر العاجل الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
اصابه اعه 44 عسكريا في معارك قطاع غزه في
الساعات ال
24 الاخيره اذا 44 عسكريا اسرائيليا
اصيبوا في الساعات ال 24 الاخيره وفق
الجيش جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكمل
اسماعيل نعم والمساعدات التي وصلت الى
شمال قطاع غزه هي مساعدات بسيطه ولم يصل
سوى شاحنات بسيطه جدا لكن هناك احتياج
كبير للدقيق احتياج كبير للمياه احتياج
كبير للمعلبات بالاضافه الى الغاز
والبترول الذي لم يصل الى شمال غزه منذ
انتهاء الهدنه وا فشل المفاوضات في مختلف
الملفات الان لم يصل هذه لم يصل مثل هذه
المساعدات باتا الى مناطق مدينه غزه
فالاحتلال بالاضافه الى ذلك لم يوصل الى
شمال قطاع غزه اي من المساع في ظل خروج
القطاع الصحي بشكل كامل عن الخدمه
واستمرار عمليات الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه
فيضطر المواطنون نقل اصاباتهم من شمال
قطاع غزه الى مستشفى الشفاء الذي يعاني من
ازمه كبيره وضغط كبير من الاصابات ونقصان
في الكادر الطبي والادوات الطبيه شكرا
جزيلا لك من مستشفى الشفاء في غزه اسماعيل
الغول مراسل الجزيره